c'est un brûlant ménage à trois
france turquie union européenne emmanuel
macron a décidé une nouvelle fois de
taper du poing sur la table
le ministère français des armées a
annoncé la suspension temporaire de sa
participation à la mission si guardian
organisé en mer méditerranée par l'otan
une mission censée faire respecter
l'embargo sur les armes en libye
il ne nous paraît pas sain de maintenir
des moyens dans une opération censée
parmi ces différentes tâches contrôler
l'embargo avec des alliés qui ne le
respecte pas en ligne de mire la turquie
le 10 juin dernier incident en mer
méditerranée
la frégate française le courbet opérant
sous commandement de l'alliance
atlantique aurait été ciblé par les
radars d'attac du bâtiment militaire
turc go kova la marine française
souhaitez contrôler un cargo battant
pavillon tanzanien sous escorte turcs
eux considérés comme suspects ankara a
expliqué que ces navires protéger une
livraison de matériel médical en libye
or le cargo en question on revient
accosté en libye
mais pour y livrer du matériel militaire
ce que réfute le gouvernement de recep
tayyip erdogan
il faut regarder ce que dit la france à
propos de ce qu'il s'est passé en
méditerranée avec cette même honnêteté
la france n'a pas dit la vérité ni à
l'union européenne ni à l'otan il n'est
pas vrai que nos bateaux ont visé le
navire français nous l'avons prouvé avec
documents et rapports à l'appui belga la
ministre française des armes et florence
parly a déclaré que l'attitude menaçant
de la frégate turque était inacceptable
et d'ajouter que la france jouit je cite
du soutien de huit alliés européens dans
des pays majeurs
depuis l'alliance atlantique a ouvert
une enquête sur l'incident naval
je considère qu'aujourd'hui la turquie
ne respectent aucun des engagements pris
à la conférence de berlin a accru sa
présence militaire en libye depuis et a
massivement réimporter des combattants
djihadistes depuis des scieries je pense
que c'est une responsabilité historique
et criminel pour qui prétend être un
membre de l'otan une brouille
diplomatique alimenté par des échanges
dette
isation à distance la turquie accuse la
france d'être à l'origine du chaos
libyen et de soutenir le maréchal haftar
et la france accuse la turquie de ne pas
respecter ses engagements et de fournir
des armes au gouvernement d'union
nationale le gn la france que macron
dirigent ou plutôt qu'ils n'arrivent pas
à diriger en ce moment ne se trouvent en
libye que pour défendre ses intérêts
avec une mentalité destructrice d'un
côté l'otan considère la russie comme
une menace mais de l'autre la france
membre de l'otan cherchent à renforcer
la présence de la russie en libye
en amont du déplacement de joseph
bourrel à ankara le porte parole du chef
de la diplomatie européenne a rappelé
que la turquie reste est candidate à une
adhésion à l'union européenne est un
état membre de l'otan
à la demande de paris les ministres
européens des affaires étrangères vont
se réunir le 13 juillet prochain pour
discuter d'une réponse commune au défi
turc